welcome back so we're talking about data
science kind of how you can ask and
answer questions with data as a primary
tool so I think of this as data-driven
inquiry or hypothesis design and testing
and I want to talk now about how this is
being used in complex manufacturing
processes so I think you know data
science has been transformative and how
data intensive fields of science are run
like astronomy
you know Genome Sciences also a lot of
tech companies that are data rich and
really data centric or data intensive
but increasingly data science is
changing how we think about complex
engineering and industrial processes so
I think about you know manufacturing or
design where you have maybe a complex
supply chain feeding into a
manufacturing process where you put all
those pieces together and you get
something you know it's much more than
the sum of its parts out and so I'm
going to talk a little bit about how
data science fits into these more
industrial manufacturing applications
and so this is really related to two
efforts one is called digital twin
digital twin and the other is called
digital thread and these are kind of how
how data science is impacting design of
complex engineering systems like
aircraft okay so and I'll just very very
briefly go over this this is like you
could have a whole lecture series on
digital twin a digital thread this is
just the overview the digital twin is a
data informed model of your complex
system and not just you know in the past
we've had lots of models of aerodynamics
or you know composite processes we have
these kind of local models the digital
twin is really an agglomeration a kind
of mega model that models all of the
different scales and aspects of a larger
process like a whole main
factoring process this really is
supposed to be a digital version of that
physical physical entity and what what's
really important about these digital
twins it's not just a model it's a model
that is pinned to measurement data so
you have all of this rich data about
that process you're collecting all of
this data so this is related to things
like the Internet of Things where you'll
start having sensors and instrumentation
kind of ubiquitous instrumentation and
that data is going to be coming in and
informing these souped-up models on
steroids essentially so you can model
your whole Factory as a digital twin
people are talking about how to model
kind of the you know the human body as a
digital twin things like that
the digital thread is the data pipeline
that enables that digital twin so the
digital thread means that you're going
to be collecting information throughout
the entire process from design to
sourcing of materials all throughout the
supply chain to when those start to be
assembled and created into this into
this large assembled objects like think
of a turbine or an aircraft something
you know that's that's many many pieces
many people putting their design and
engineering you know capabilities to
build this thing the digital thread is
this digital signature that that tracks
all of those parts and all of those
pieces and all of those processes all
the measurements you take of the system
throughout that procedure go into this
digital thread and what that allows you
to do is first of all ask much much more
sophisticated questions about what
upstream processes are affecting
downstream either issues or quality
concerns or things like that and so you
have this much clearer feedback between
the questions you can ask in this this
digital thread okay so I mean I really
simple I think if the digital thread is
this kind of you know arrow of time and
you see kind of these processes as they
get pulled in maybe you know all my
rivets I follow my rivets the whole time
through the process and the composite
processes and and you see this kind of
complexity in all these inner week
moving pieces
but everything has a digital signature
so you can kind of trace and do
surveillance and and supervision of the
process and understand like what is most
correlated with some downstream thing
that I want to either improve or make
more reproducible things like that okay
so I think this is really exciting you
have your your digital twin model your
digital thread which is the data
pipeline and architecture that
facilitates that digital twin and this
allows you to do kind of amazing amazing
things both now and in the future so I'm
gonna oversimplify a complex
manufacturing process into a few steps
so let's say you have some design and
this is complicated multi objective you
know there's cost there's time there's
you know uncertainty in this entire
design process maybe you have your
manufacturing process and again this
could you know it's one word here this
is a whole Factory
multiple factories hundreds of factories
maybe across the globe working kind of
in this this very intricate dance okay
and so of course your design and your
manufacturing should be inherently
linked once you make something it goes
into the real world maybe it has to be
certified so you know certification or
validation testing and then maybe when
it actually goes into the real world you
collect kind of let's say then it goes
out into the real world and you might
want to collect data on how it's
actually performing in the real world
and so of course these are not all done
in isolation today but what the digital
twin and digital thread will hopefully
allow in the future is having much
tighter feedback between these different
these different core aspects of design
and manufacturing certification and then
tying that to real-world performance
maintenance things like that and maybe
even in the design phase you know what's
the business model who are you gonna
sell these products to what what needs
does it fill and so really kind of
giving feedback at all of these
different
levels you know kind of coupling back to
the design phase and the manufacturing
and and tying these together in a more
kind of tightly coupled and holistic
view is really the goal of this digital
to an end digital thread and I think the
way I think about this you might have a
lot of historical data that you can use
to inform the next
well maybe you can improve your current
manufacturing your current certification
your current designs but maybe you can
also use that information so that the
next product that's being designed for
manufacturability you can kind of
incorporate that knowledge into future
designs and so so there's a lot of first
of all there's a lot to unpack here this
is just a very shallow overview of very
very deep subjects and these are under
continuous development so these are
relatively kind of hot ideas lots of
people are investing lots of time
understanding what is the best way of
building digital twins and digital
threat architectures to improve these
systems so this is really exciting and
there's gonna be a lot of development
but the idea is that this can massively
kind of lift the fog that has made us
develop so much in isolation with with
with handoff so we can kind of take away
some of that fog and make it much
clearer how different decisions upstream
affect things downstream okay thank you